parti très vite ils sont ici temps de
les piéger
non non tout de suite moi j'aime
beaucoup peut-être qu'ils ont moins
d'être déjà au moins 14 ou 17 24 24
heures depuis délaissé le coup de bluff
bon c'est pas passé ils ont tout de
suite réagi derrière et ça s'organise et
suffit pas de vent donc savez qui est
arrivé à piton que je connaissais pas
que si j'allais m'attaquer monde
j'essaie de rester comme nous l'a
ensuite attaqué chez avec boris de la
conterie encore donc qui dit qu'il faut
me laisser un portillon pour ce que
c'est pas trop s'organiser rapidement
devant c'est encore ma chance pour la
suite mais vite organiser les autres
équipes ne sont pas passées pour nous
aider pas seul en place tant j'ai aussi
vous ont préféré laisser la chance
en équipant ses c'est la course
maintenant je veux le maillot mais le
tour n'est pas fini tu es là pour
continuer de l'animé non là je pense que
maintenant ils me suis bien battu a mais
je continue quand même et je continue je
continuais me back qui avait un objectif
c'est le tour de martin quand tu
prépares ici c'est pas mal de matadi pas
trop dire
[Musique]
de quoi se donner moi
avec les gars et son travail et sa femme
en tenue oui je pense que c'est peut
être monter une petite chose vite fait
que ça peut être le repos aussi donc on
verra comment ça se passe et pour la
danse